okay we just had to turn the mics back
on breaking news Jeffrey Epstein found
injured in New York City jail cell after
possible suicide attempt accused
pedophile in wealthy Manhattan financier
Jeffrey Epstein was found injured and in
a fetal position inside his cell at New
York City Jail according to sources
close to the investigation Epstein who
is being held in the Metropolitan
Corrections Center during his trial for
conspiracy and sex trafficking was found
semi-conscious with marks on his neck to
source of told News 4
investigators are trying to piece
together exactly what happened saying
the details remain murky - sources say
that Epstein may have tried to hang
himself while the third source cautioned
that the injuries were not serious and
questions if Epstein might be using it
as a way to get a transfer a fourth
source said an assault had not been
ruled out that another inmate was
questioned that inmate was nicholas
Tartaglia on tour Technion was a former
police officer in westchester county who
was arrested in December 2016 and
accused of killing four men in an
alleged cocaine distribution conspiracy
then burying their bodies in his
Otisville yard in Orange County sources
told news for investigators questioned
torchic Doolin and the former cop
claimed not to have seen anything and
it's just that he did not touch have
steam the attorney for Tartaglia denied
all the claims that his client attacked
the financier saying his client I've
seen get along well they're in the same
unit and doing well Epstein is now on
suicide watch all right Raymond yeah I
mean so he's in gen-pop or something you
would think they put them in protective
custody he's in the Metropolitan
Corrections Center which is where El
Chapo was okay and it's downtown in New
York and we walked by when we shot that
video because we went down to the court
it's it's very close to the this you
know Southern District to the federal
courthouse and that's where he's being
capped supposedly it's more secure than
Gitmo although this you know well I mean
you know oh you know I mean this is what
it's been said about it but they only
you strapped like you like shorted
someone's balls there at that point well
they're or they or they do and they just
do it more efficiently than a Gitmo
but apparently it's a similar type of
thing where a lot of these people are in
solitary for a 23 hours a day or
whatever I think that's kind of what it
is maybe not I don't know
for that one hour to get along pretty
well I guess I don't know you know it's
interesting you know we were just
talking about if you're a guy like
Epstein do you take yourself out well
here's the thing because he is you know
maybe we're an idea at this point like
heat this whole thing he's kind of a
scammer right his whole thing has turned
out to be his empires kind of [ __ ]
is a bad thing yeah he was given that 90
mil or that 70 million dollar town house
in Manhattan by less wax know who was
the head of Victoria's Secret nobody
really knows anybody that works at
Jeffery Epstein's hedge fund it's
probably just some type of fronter yeah
money laundering whatever it's possible
this is like a Madoff thing even well
yeah there was that article that he
wasn't really a billionaire right but no
one's actually saying that the actual
investments are like [ __ ] are they
right well nobody knows does anyone know
any of the investors I think it's kind
of just playing with him I mean they
maybe hear about it was apparently but
people be like I wanna you know get in
on this he say a billion dollars or
nothing you have to you have to front a
billion dollars we can't get crazy so I
get but that was made of smooth
basically Wow it was a billion but
wasn't that right it was something like
that point is this is a guy who's made a
fake imagine like he's a bunch of all
Jews and I'm like I lost all my money
with this human trafficking racket this
is ridiculous traffic is not a stable
business world come on this guy's got
presidents [ __ ] these kids and you
telling me my returns say everyone needs
bread everyone needs milk everyone needs
a [ __ ] kid hey Warren Buffett baby I'm
at the bread room yeah I'm afraid of
course
hey everyone needs bread Warren
Buffett's like this is a blue chip this
is a stock that you that grows so I do
so Gomez Cocteau is the blue chip yeah I
don't know I think if I'm AB steena and
I know that I could be killed or I know
that because I mean even with flipping
this guy's not seeing the outside of
jail cell I would think not
I mean it's too much maybe in 10 years
when everyone stops caring look at me to
meet you like died yeah this was just a
little different no it's just a little
different than you know I have less
faith in the people than you I guess
good point is you probably spend less
his life in jail but this is a guy who's
basically you know he wasn't he
didn't like he's not some guy who's like
a talented artist or a talented
businessman who feels like he gives like
once he he can get out and then ten
years build a new business empire he fee
scammed his way in and that only works
one thrill you can't go back to the well
and make a new scam but there's a guy
like this who's probably been on the
inner circle for his entire life and
he's been privy to things and he's
probably done things and been been privy
to things and other people in power have
done yeah that are so wild uh does a guy
like this he just said you know and he's
rotting in the Metropolitan Corrections
Center in New York but does he have a
psychic break where he goes like what
the [ __ ] how did I how did this happen
or is is he like pragmatically almost
going my life will never be what it was
the only thing yeah we're never gonna
build it back so definitely even if he
built it with talent you're never
building it back there's this there's
probably be stories close I mean like
this is a yeah maybe this is it's bad
it's you're not your you're your only
hope here yeah is to flip in a way that
gets you some better deal which how much
better you know yeah I mean like first
of all does any prosecutor really want
Clinton or Trump on this like I mean Sir
James Combes daughter is part of the
team that's prosecuting him which makes
me think that the types of people that
they're choosing our establishment
people the people there would be the
people are pickin to prosecute me yeah
she's on the game I you know yeah and
I'm saying is like I maybe sing it in a
cynical way of like they're not gonna
convict on their own but like the it's
book this guy is universally prima at
this point now seen as a pedophile
serial pedophile a monster do you really
want to take a bite at the Apple of
bringing down a guy who you know
Clinton's a little diminished but still
do to the country if you saw those two
guys or even one of them get tarred with
this even to the extent that they're
it's not it's they don't get convicted
or there's no jail but that it's it's
it's so much so that like that we have
ex-presidents now in the news
you know being accused or potentially
indicted the country becomes you me and
Nick Bryant just like Emily that's a
wild if people I'll why have you heard
that remember that what a fun country
just like it with everyone had the
knowledge because we've had the
knowledge right we could've been wrong
but we've had the knowledge in our heads
that like yeah these guys are doing this
for a couple years
is there a some type of massive like you
look at late-night TV you look at you me
foul and how it's like singing songs
with my pets and how he's playing
checkers with Cameron Diaz while the
world burns well and and you know
certain people and enjoy that is there
some just cognitive dissonance where I
met like people just fly into a fantasy
world look he's a rapist yeah even
though it should have required a new
documentary Michael Jackson is now seen
as a pedophile right I'm of the most
beloved polity like yeah the love and
Clinton never was I know but there's
something about an American pressure no
it's I'm saying is and there seems to be
very little ramifications of that as far
as like you would think there'd be some
kind of you know elevation of
consciousness of like you know cynicism
of like awareness of my half it all just
forces that play that all I go beyond
just our petty I'll take some work and
no it doesn't seem to do any of that I
mean even without the Epstein thing you
know and regardless of a lot of the
Trump stuff but like even Trump of his
own daughters weird and people just
gonna have were there like there's a lot
of I think his name a lot of people [ __ ]
kids yeah I think a lot of people have
been [ __ ] as kids from the West did
yeah and you know there's a none of
those people around they they kind of
like what do you want admitted not to go
yeah we kind of this is just what it is
just like it's like they'll accept it
and I'm happy about it
but this is not like the biggest it was
a shock to me yeah I think it [ __ ] as
a kid I was shocked I was shocked that I
wasn't far as I was gorgeous joerger
looking good great I was a cute kid if
there was ever time to [ __ ] me it was
that Mama's for was very cute
well it's perspective but there was ever
time to [ __ ] me it was when I was
younger um yeah the the thing that I
look at here is like are
do you believe yeah that there are
people that are going AB singh's gotta
go I think that is very very possible
that the CIA or some parallel
organization on same level was you was
possibly utilizing him as an asset right
yeah because he's in with all these
people potentially and so yeah if that
those kind of people let's just say
Mossad was use him right they would
easily would absolutely kill him oh if
they could slain Maxwell who's whose
father Robert Maxwell other than being a
media mogul was you know in in in a in a
biography and and and it you know widely
believed to have been you know mi6 asset
or whatever really you know yeah
oh yeah and his daughter was ever sick
no different no this is a different
playing Robert Maxwell just slain his
slain Maxwell right right her her father
oh she's the one that was like best
friends over Chelsea Clinton for a while
I don't know it was dark libido
all I know is that she flew in the
rarefied air of society that Epstein did
not I mean Epstein was a math teacher at
Dalton which was a very elite prep
school right but and he had some
connections but it's still a far cry
from knowing world leaders and
presidents and also in those worlds like
he's still the help of that point short
and exactly but just Layne Maxwell was
the connector to that I Shalon of
society for him yeah and she was kind of
a pimp she went out and recruited girls
for him right what what drives cuz
here's a yeah so she comes from this
gray background
you know correct I get it if like the
other way around but like if he's
purveying the girls for some guy who's
like you know Matt like if it was
maximum sup yeah is that the thing is
max well it was a maximum [ __ ] his
daughter potentially and then and she's
kind of you know sometimes he gets weird
and they kind of I mean if in that
scenes getting girls for how deep and
dark it goes anyone's guess my point is
like is it's not so much that she's
pervane for him is he purveying it's
you're recruiting girls in their early
teens right to go have sex and you don't
have a problem with it there's a very
good chance that you were molested but
that you were victimized or
you're on you're a sociopath for Benassi
you know like whatever yeah from the
Franklin scare but like I don't know
anything about just saying Maxwell or I
mean let's be let's be hardened cynics
here for a minute you know this is
potentially just how somebody like her
people are people want power but people
obviously like money but these people
have money I mean I've seen didn't but
Maxwell certainly did
but people like power they like
connections their deviant their they
like you know do you think cuz these
girls I doubt these girls came from
pedigreed backgrounds one second I
wouldn't imagine I mean they may not be
you know look the trail you know
trailer-park people but they're probably
not and so my point is you think that's
part of it that these people who were
part of these like you know this small
group of families is ritual bleats we're
gonna call them they really just view
the average person that's like kind of
animals and livestock yes to be used yes
100% yeah and Nick Malin made a point
he's like well a lot of these people sit
at their desk and press a button in a
village blows up right how much further
away from that is [ __ ] a kid or
whatever you know but what's interesting
to me is that you have a potential
situation where Epstein is going to
named co-conspirators or they're gonna
name P and there's a revenue here
there's already been attorneys like
wanna I think was because Alan
Dershowitz is implicated in this he's
defending a buddy implicated he's been
accused of yeah been accused oh I hear
that oh he's been a cute and so David
Boies who's actually you know these are
the same attorneys from like Bush v Gore
yeah but the guy that David Boies or
whatever his name is nameplate Beckwith
jr. please write in the in the HBO movie
he's on the other side so it's like
another legal showdown or was I think
illegal should I and I think he was
quoted or some attorney was quoted as
saying that had been close to the case
that like there's a lot of bold-faced
names here right that if these documents
get leaked there's gonna be a lot of
people well here let me look to of
course trying to like drove sand on the
fire here whatever it's called but like
point is these kind of people would also
be buying people off warning people so
I'm not holding war for der schweiz I'm
yeah did if you have a hundred people at
least a couple dozen of them are
probably not [ __ ] kids but you know
you have this like organization well so
Nick Price who this gets to the black
dude right so Nick Brian had leaked the
black book to Gawker the house manager
Jeffrey Epstein had tried to sell the
black book and I think an undercover FBI
agent caught him trying to sell it which
is kind of part and parcel of what
people do in these situations they're
like I got this little nugget of wisdom
you know I got this thing that's
valuable these [ __ ] have no money
growth they want money doesn't mean the
black books fake doesn't mean you know
now in the black book which had everyone
from New York in it so it doesn't it had
a lot of wealthy people right and
they're not all pedophiles they're not
all guilty some of them had no idea what
FC was doing but there was there were
names in the black book that were
circled and Brian had said that an
investigator on the case told him that
those names were circled I think by the
house manager potentially or by somebody
as potential material witnesses the
house manager ID was that the the person
who gave the black book had circled
those names and potential I think
material witnesses and if I'm almost
positive than it was the house manager
would circle doesn't if nothing yep yeah
I think would haven't had to be oh yeah
you know who has a black book was
basically like I think these people or
as that guy gave it to Nick Bryant I I
think he got it he know it was discovery
in a court case
oh [ __ ] about okay and then Nick Bryant
got a hold of it okay but if the house
manager didn't circle the names of the
material witnesses which I think he did
it might have been the investigators who
did right and they had reason to believe
that whoever they circled was a material
witness but there it there will be some
way to differentiate just rich people in
his circle right from potential because
that's the thing like this is a guy look
at Madoff for instance what is this
temple I mean just out of curiosity I
mean it's just maybe it's just a temple
maybe just want some beautiful island it
looks like a [ __ ] I mean I showed you
a picture right now and here it's uh
well you don't find them and look at
Madoff and you're like look he's a
scanner he scammed people he has the guy
owners as a meth
and like all sorts of [ __ ] you know
Pete powerful people who only connection
he has is that he like you know he
scammed them and like they were
investing in this thing so I'm sure
there is that level of I mean here's a
temple well it's more like a moths I'm
sure I'm very comp the temple it does
look like a mosque it's got some kind of
like we're it looks like a hedge maze
from the shining on the side but not
like actually hedges I mean listen
there's all kinds of you know people on
4chan or whatever they're theorizing and
reddit they're all kinda see rising all
kinds of things about it it's a dungeon
it's this it's that there is something
wild that this is a private island but
there's something that adds to the
intrigue that obviously he has this jet
it's called a lolita express but there's
also this island and this adds an
element to it that is wild because even
in the franklin scandal or like you know
from what i you know from you know the
reading the book and having Nick on and
the people that did who took Shaunie
that Netflix I mean nobody talked about
an island this was just hotel rooms and
whatever the idea that this guy's got
his own island we other was a thing
wasn't um
not during the Franklin scandal no back
Daniel attend your back
yeah like did this seems like the idea
that it's an island Brian it adds
another element of of wild right and
then it's got a [ __ ] temple on it and
that it's this mysterious shadowy
billionaire and he's connected to print
like it's everything a conspiracy needs
and it's not a conspiracy Clinton claims
he never went to the I sure yeah and he
probably did it he was probably not
stupid enough to set foot on that right
well what he did on that jet who knows
yeah but the thing is this was like yeah
why do you need a jelly whatever I mean
right well it likes all right to travel
right sure by mean you can get I'm sure
there's other yeah non kids like what
point is why sort of Clinton let's just
say Clinton's not involved but he know
he has he has involvement nobody it
wasn't doing it so what is the allure of
this guy like what is going to be the
counter-argument that no he was just
this guy who built that ostentatious
buildings this private like worth what
was your plausible deniability what did
you think this guy was that he was a
philanthropist that he was wealthy that
he was connected that he had parties
that a lot was my point will they will
there be a narrative that comes out well
well he would throw he's a very
elaborate uh you know bought gavel is
that this [ __ ] weird Mecca yeah well
I mean so he had a mansion in Manhattan
he had a match and I believe in New
Mexico or castle in New Mexico something
weird yeah and he had this privately
owned two islands actually great st.
James and little st. James right little
st. James was the one that I think they
you know that he lived on or that he had
a residence I was permanent residence
and a lot of these women have claimed to
have been molested you know on the side
North Pole I don't know what island they
were on but these guys who like workers
on the I guess the bigger Island maybe
would see him like every week or
whatever coming in with these young
girls and be right apparently tip very
well so no one really wanted to talk she
um yeah I always had the impression as
the island was like some secluded like
tropical island but do you think
somebody gives somebody money in the
Metropolitan Corrections Center and just
goes get get off this guy that's messy
it's messy every look alright so there's
a couple layers here it is the ever seen
it was the company for instance yeah
yeah you know company you know my home
you know a we mean the Culinary
Institute of America at Hyde Park New
York but in this food you know you would
you would hope that they have I mean
some guy what what's the move you get
you get a guy in there who's like a
guard or you credentials or you go to
one of these [ __ ] that's facing some
crazy time right and you try to go
listen we you know you scratch our back
we scratch your I mean I don't know it's
all very messy that's a good point
because it's not the CIA doesn't mind
having a failed first attempt Rio in the
Iranian coup went a little sideways yeah
yeah I mean maybe yeah always the
cleanest you know maybe it's just
showing Epstein this is the direction
it's heading sure I mean do you think
does he fear that I mean look you know
you you don't think he's likely he tried
to kill himself we think it's kind of a
no I know if I was a guy like him you
know who's lived this insane crazy life
I mean there's a guy like that just try
to go out in the in a spectacular blaze
of glory and name every person and just
say liked it or or do you like almost
old-school mafia go not that I'm
comparing them because they weren't you
know [ __ ] kids but like any type of
old-school criminal where you would just
say to yourself I'm done and I'm just
gonna go out how I'm gonna go out and
I'm not gonna does any part of him think
if I really blow the whistle on
everything it potentially destroys the
country or is it like do you know is
there really a motive like is he using
it like it would have to be an act of
like almost like the Joker or pure chaos
because it's a guy who's done he's lived
his life the way he's lived it
these terrible things and these people
were his kind of his friends and
Patriots I mean if he's not doing it to
get off if he's just doing it to blow it
up I mean you think he's just a sadist
who does it for like the shits and
giggles I know I just wonder just to be
have the ego of like being infamous that
I just wonder if a guy at the end of his
life what I mean because this is a guy
who thought he was out he'd been through
this before he got rien how does he does
he does he drop a dime on everybody and
and just say this goes to the very top
and I'm gonna explain you exactly how
your society is run and how these laws
have been you know completely ignored
and perverted and you know or is he
gonna just take it to the grave or I
mean do you think that even reverberates
people people yeah the Catholic Church
and Rhyno and Michael Jack I'll say it's
a game like
people are kind of stupidly like but
Epstein was kind of central to pizza
gate I will be honest with you right now
pizza gate now not that I've ever bought
into the more ridiculous claims right
but anyone dismissing the pizza gay
people now I think is wrong right well
the idea of common Pizza being the thing
yeah but I mean the idea of pizza gate
we're like powerful people and there's
email my whole thing is like yes does he
try to use it as a bargaining chip
potentially but he knows there's only so
far that'll go right so I think there's
the calculations gotta be more of like
do you just check out maybe I would just
try to kill myself I'm saying because
it's what these men do they have a case
do they still move it just lay max well
do they still move in her probably right
she's a co-conspirator they can indict
her I mean he have a family right bring
in the pride thinks noogie and like I'm
sure he look he's he's probably doesn't
care that much about weighing macula his
buddies his friends yeah I don't think
he's like okay you cannot cut in her
name right I've said it five times max
well just lame-o just when she GH is
just lame yeah she should ended up with
you I mean I got what she French I could
I could deal with that it's the British
but go on I think what will separate
date well though she no I can't I can't
be seen with her point is somehow still
it was her who can't be seen with you
even though she's running a human
trafficking ring and it's in the press
this doesn't hear there's there's
multiple levels of questions is there it
could this have operated without the
complicity of the security apparatus nah
I don't think so right on some level and
we don't know we don't mean that it's
really Sarah Lee when we talk about the
national security of apparatus it's
important for people to understand that
it's like rogue groups of operators
within these agencies all right I mean
sure wasn't a rogue operation but sure
no and I'm not saying that this
necessarily is necessarily a rogue
operation either but it's not common
knowledge in the CIA that a lot like I
don't believe that I do believe there
are pockets of deep covered dark
like black dough means more like you
know look this guy's an asset and the
same way that was whitey bulger a lot of
people in CAA did not know MK was going
on sure I was happy
yeah my point is like wasn't think
whitey bulger was a rat for years right
and you let them get away with other
stuff yeah that kind of thing which is
so deplorable but it's like you know
it's not like they're [ __ ] going out
and I was it was probably a honeypot
yeah meant to ensnare people that it was
just you had information on powerful
people that they were doing these things
um these are all he's interesting good
like if you don't weird to me and
somebody brought up a good point
don't any of them know it's a honeypot I
don't don't like whatever it is like
like I guess there's just no level of
like turn it it's almost like I almost
imagine like a Yelp or I'm like oh they
[ __ ] me at this restaurant you know
it's like I get facebook messages from
bikini girls yeah yeah Ryan's fake yeah
yeah I agree to it but they have money
so I guess that's part of the idea that
nobody turns around it goes hey be
careful about that island because guess
what I went there and now I got all
kinds of problem but I guess I mean I
guess the idea is that it's this
mutually assured destruction
everybody goes down or nobody goes down
right that's what I think they all kind
of believe that everybody is protected
on that say in that segment of society
do you think there's also a level of
community there's no other thing to
bring up I brought up with Nick Bryan
remember I remember yeah he's like yeah
this is deplorable but these are also
not like little kids and you think a
certain level of like well is it because
we do know there are situations we're
like with the government and everything
where they're like [ __ ] little kids
well here's the thing we don't know that
well so we don't but the triangle is
going to seems to be it seems to be not
at the top level of government but we'd
over there was a weird some weird
chicken went on with boys town and yeah
kids whoa yeah we know that was that was
prepubescent kids some of them yeah yeah
so I'm saying like this seems to be
mostly older kids I don't know yeah well
you think that helps people look the
other way
more I don't know I'm just saying like I
don't know I mean
I understand I think I see what you see
I'm good now I see you again again or
can see like how could you like it is
like you know it's not 13 is young now
it's 13
yeah no about 13 warranty a lot of these
girls
oh that's very young birth and we don't
know it's all bad but that's like we
don't know that it's not younger sure I
actually I actually believe that it
probably is because the the links that a
lot of these people have taken to
protect what they're doing and the hoops
that you're jumping through suggests
that the activities are nefarious to a
degree and on a level that would suggest
that it's it's people that are you know
either barely pre Besant Pripet you know
because we've always kind of discussed
this 17 and 18 year old no real
difference wait till they're 8 like yeah
yeah and you look at porn there's plenty
of legal porn actors in book young yeah
I think why yeah and they everybody's
been on porn websites we look at
something like this doesn't seem right
let me get out of here yeah but they say
those little dumb disclaimers only
everybody's 18 but I think it's bad yeah
and I think it's and and I think it's
bad but it's also very interesting how
reckless they are that there's just all
of these women that are able to come
like can any of them identify Clinton
well I mean any of these but identify
somebody like on that level like a prime
minister or somebody like that does that
mean is that why make any claim wasn't
part of this but is that why the go
heads and the [ __ ] you know and the
real satanic [ __ ] because jested that
that type of stuff
it gives deniability when people are
coming out and saying these things it is
it you know if a kid comes out and says
I was molested by somebody that was
dressed up like a demon or you know you
know people are more likely to say oh
you had a bad dream this was a nightmare
right exactly you know hey you know
these girls are like walking around with
like he takes them shopping I guess
these fancy places well that's the thing
you can't take them shopping in a goat
head right no I'm not saying that the
the
don't know are these girls at the time
I'm sure it's right to a degree yes
doesn't matter
listen yeah they are drugged this is a
shame oh they're promised drugs and
money they're young you're
impressionable that they're potentially
abused themselves absolutely they're not
through forcing them in a car right
they're taking them shopping all right
Billy speak to your point liability I
don't think Clinton would be that
reckless of underage girls like he's not
that dumb wow this is a guy that's been
credibly accused of rape no he look he's
a rapist yeah my all that above age yeah
these are abuzz I think you know after
look back in the day sure I think I was
what you would think he learned to be a
little more careful of my voice he back
before the Internet yeah you know back
when you know Larry King Lawrence E king
and the Franklin scandal bro these
victims couldn't find each other there
were no way I mean these stories were
absolutely we're not getting printed in
any [ __ ] I mean they were getting
printed papers but they were like lurid
conspiracies in a 60 minutes think of
the six minutes they had a thing about
it was a BBC doc of called about boys
town called conspiracy of silence and it
just stopped production on it look and
it didn't air and you could still see
the rough cut footage on YouTube but
they just killed a lot of these [ __ ]
stories and the stories it did make it
like there was a big Washington Post or
washing times I forget where it's like
homosexual prostitution inquiry ensnares
Bush a Reagan Bush White House and then
everybody started to get killed right
you know like you had Gary kara Dory
who's the private investigator who said
he found photos of this get killed
you had Alicia Owen who was the girl
that came out and said all this should
happen her get put in solitary
confinement
convicted of perjury you had a bunch of
people starting to die you had her
brother get killed you had here you're a
lot of bodies body started you had
William Colby it was a CIA director but
who was looking into this they find them
in a [ __ ] canoe yeah this is the guy
from the Phoenix row so like they
stacked bodies to prevent the Franklin
scandal from coming out if you don't
know what that is it's [ __ ] you go
google it we've done a million shows on
it
but what do they do here I mean look
these are people who speak to the whole
thing all your people gonna like lose
their minds over this is this that big a
deal
I mean look the ethically her you said
wants it if they if Cheney came out and
said we did 9/11 you said no one would
care it was the funniest thing I've ever
heard
basically like just three guys in a bar
in Levittown and like Chinese Chinese on
TVs all right listen we did 9/11
you see you thought that you're so
cynical that you thought these three
guys are like I don't know they finally
date they did 9/11 all right gulf of
tonkin york 701 keratea Slater why
didn't mean like at the boy so you said
it literally if they came out it was the
funniest thing ever don't backtrack
you've ever said come on
you said myself feel away I feel like
you know you said I think you might say
they did 9/11 nobody really I mean I
think it I think it'd be a little bit
crazier than you would imagine say look
at the Catholic Church the Pope will
give the Ireland just one down
yeah the Pope is still like there's
these they still have there's some oun
[ __ ] thing like knows why they here's
why the Catholic Church is less of a
thing yeah it's faceless like you have
all these Cardinals and [ __ ] and you
like bring up Bernard law but you nobody
knows these [ __ ] are okay we're
talking bold-faced names that you kind
of grown up with being accused of
sexually molesting children and an
island
I feel never know here's a problem yeah
it's it's gonna be this it's gonna be a
lot of accusations
yeah they look they're gonna have the
best offense of course and but they're
gonna go with these house and it's gonna
be I mean if the if the girls are
testifying it's different I guess one
picture it's gonna be they're gonna be
Epstein it's gonna be the ravings of a
madman who's being corner and he's
trying to like you know I think the
girls who can come listen I don't know
what they're planning to do it's a very
hard for me to believe that anybody
faces any real consequences just because
I'm a [ __ ] I'm yeah awake to an
extent and you know but if the girls are
gonna come in and finger big people like
Clinton
Trump took the Prime Minister's yes yes
like a couple of people know I'm friends
with like Tony Blair I'm not well they
said a prime minister oh okay
so what I mean I don't know I don't know
I maybe not Tony Blair but why not Tony
right probably Blair why not son hey why
else when you go along with you Iraq let
me listen I'm like am I gonna run the
type of show here where I think twice
about just suggesting to Tony Blair's
raping kids without any evidence at all
no Steve Jobs maybe they somebody said
uh Prime Minister I think dude I think
it's billionaires big money people
people we've never heard of senators
senators congressmen I think Basil's me
I don't want to I think it's not great
to just start naming people that were
[ __ ] the kids without an e with
literally no evident be famous people
yet Midler yeah I know I don't think
this is the right way to go about this
Oh Anthony Edwards for me are we start
naming random people but now look if
you're CIA I'm back did you do it clean
you try to give him a [ __ ] heart
attack would you make it about nine they
supposedly have oh yeah well they give a
syringe in the tOA's you learn first of
all you see my go plane yeah how hard is
it to bribe some New York City cops it's
gotta be pretty easy right bad those
guys to look the other way what do you
need a slice a meatball parm we had such
a funny we said we think that video to
have scenes have you know then we said
one of the kids was helping his film we
go to Metropolitan Detention Center
we're staring at it I'm like go and ask
if that scenes in there right and and
and I'm like I can't because I'm dressed
like a schoolgirl and I have a sign that
says free Jeffrey right so I can't walk
up to the guard standing outside you go
do that so this kid Christoph is sweet
kid
um he helps out with the clips for the
show he walks up to the guy and I'm like
thinking that the guy is gonna be like
get out of here
you know he asked the guy and it's so
funny the Kazakh I don't know he's
upstate in there you know el Chapo's in
here I don't know just keep talking and
I'm like I would think that this guy big
get the [ __ ] out of here again I'm not
answering any of you quiet
this guy's like I don't know what's
going up like I worked oh forget I
worked in the jail yeah not you know
that one I never chapo but you know I
interacted while these guys they hated
me after a while this doesn't an
incident but what incident I joked
around back cops dying with this nurse
whose husband was a cop
and they take won't win do it I didn't
know what the guards hated you yeah they
found that an old a old side they hated
me yeah I know she was a joke because
there was like a big [ __ ] thing in
front of the police headquarters down
the block I was like well that's not a
cop cop that shot you're working in a
jail it wasn't I don't think eyes it may
not been literally that it was something
okay it was a faux pas okay yeah yeah
yeah I wasn't out of it right right
right but they didn't they didn't see it
anyway point is yes I'm from probably
until it is not a [ __ ] thing you do
like these you can get these things
witness corruption per se yeah like we
all know I mean everything everything's
getting the prison every [ __ ] day of
the year people were getting drugs also
[ __ ] porn mags anything you want and
like these people are it's the human
element it's the loose it's too loose
dread so yeah I mean I'm checking right
now to see if there's anything that's
been updated because it is it is kind of
like breaking yeah and you know it's
pretty much all the types of stories
that so I think if I can give you tell
Dora they put this in his food I mean
that's thing the guys also like Jeffery
FC moved money overseas and transaction
his bank flag to us so I think because
of who he is right
these guards are more well yeah well I'm
not gonna take a couple hundred grand to
kill some pedophile [ __ ] them yeah I
know so like yeah I mean I think it's
very possible but it's also like why
wouldn't
like what is the endgame if he doesn't
kill himself what is his life gonna be
just give me on trial but there's no
getting off of this right like they have
him he's already admitted to doing this
I know it doesn't seem like he could get
another sweetheart deal I'm learnin less
it would be hilarious if he got immunity
and just implicated some low-level
congressman you know [ __ ] you're like
Jeffrey is home on his Island tonight
because he's implicated this congressman
from Des Moines Iowa Bernie Sanders yeah
Bernie Sanders I mean I guess think what
what is the worse things have happened
but yeah I I just don't I think it's
like they didn't find a new snow they
found neck wounds but no was saying in
that right right so at they say neck
wounds some people don't try to choke
him somebody saying this is this guy's
trying to get a transfer somebody saying
another guard attacked them and somebody
saying maybe he tried to kill himself
it's there's not a ton of I mean by the
time this podcast comes out in a few
days there might be some clarity on this
right but I think the larger point of
the discussion is still really what is a
guy like you put your you're sitting in
a Cell cuz you gotta remember his old
sweetheart deal he left like six days a
week to just go back to his mansion
right on work release yeah I mean so now
he's in a Cell 8 by 8 whatever it is and
he's staring down the Southern District
in New York they're not [ __ ] around
yeah Eastern District I think it's a
Southern District and he knows that it's
gonna be over now do you think there
were people that were like do you think
a guy like that goes and lambs it if he
found out cuz he flew back to New York
and they got arrested at Teterboro right
do you think he had an inkling do you
think he yeah anyway that if if he found
out overseas you think he just lambs of
course yeah yeah I mean look he's got
even if he's they'll just kill him I
think if look I mean you don't think a
guy like that goes I'm better I'm safer
in the chest I mean I guess not
let's say I mean look I'm live in prison
sucks
ya know but he's like he's not gonna go
to a minimum-security prison like really
terrible yeah it's very least just a
excruciatingly boring
awful life what did it anyway you were
rich buy a luxurious you could if you're
in a room with him yeah and you have
five minutes and you could ask him
questions what do you do you ask him
questions you just start sucking him he
has a little egg-shaped penis that's
what he's that's what it's a really yeah
he's like deformed or whatever hungry so
what do you usually I don't talk out of
turn about people's channels but he's
done some harmful things so what do you
ask this man I mean listen look at some
of my electronic music dude think it
could go anywhere or wherever so he's
gonna answering truthfully that's what
we're seeing
we're assuming yeah yeah asking about
the Intel I mean I'm curious about like
you're right
what we like what were they using us for
what do you like good question yeah yeah
what world events that occurred were
swayed one way or the other because of
information that you will get you know
what do I know
is any of this I just somebody just gave
me an island that's the thing like we
talked about Oh what cause it still
don't say well the financial security
but it was probably if anything like
well you know we got we got this plans
for this missiles no little dynamics
could make a Miss we're so cynical that
we don't even think these people need to
be blackmailed
we're like don't these idiots just go
along with the death machine no matter
what right but I guess some of them
don't know they don't but my point is
like even the intelligence they gleaned
I'm not saying any of it would have been
worth button this happened but we just
started asking about 9/11 we're like
listen why have we not seen one vigilant
Guardian come on there's not one video
of the plane hitting the pen not one
he's just rolling his eyes and it sounds
great
he looked at me he's like did you [ __ ]
my front door Did you touch my ass
suggest she [ __ ] door yeah I was like
[ __ ] his knickers oh no I didn't do
that he's like that's a felony we did to
my problem would you ask him
are they in yeah look I think I asked
him nothing relating to that whole like
you know Baba I asked who give me names
who were the I'm like tell me one that
would shock me
give me one that would shock me who were
Chuck I don't know but I mean I'm sure
any you know well you wouldn't be
shocked if it was like some politician I
mean what was really shocking what were
like who think about this who in the
world could you not picture being a
pedophile great question um god I'm such
a cynical guy like me not there I mean
women black people really hey no black
this black pebble I'm sure there are but
I'm just saying as people that I don't
picture right I don't picture or Kelly
yeah I'm just saying you're talking
about who would shock neighbor I don't
know okay
I think I mean honestly it's LuAnn shock
yeah and it's hard
who would shock me I'm surprised about
Frank and about kids no yeah he's not
that's yeah no he's they just Jay mayor
just ran that piece yeah no she was
doing there rein her in but listen he
probably was some hit job yeah I mean
one way yellow look it might just been
you know that's the rule the coarse
aggregate
that's the rule maybe Tom Brady you know
wait is the Gisele Tom Brady's wife yeah
no yeah the Gisele in question is no you
idiot okay she's up watching and just
laying back so okay okay the this
changes everything
[Music]
wait a minute what did you just say I
asked if the Gisele that's involved with
Epstein is Tom Brady's wife no it's just
slain Maxwell that's involved with
Epstein and Giselle bunch and that's the
one who's married to Tom Brady
uh what did you think what were you
gonna say it changes everything if it
changes everything if Tom Brady is
married to like this purveyor of her
files you know that hold that the whole
Super Bowl is tarnished no I mean it's
I'm saying that everything has to be the
CIA doing it like this this [ __ ] this
Maxwell guy do it this [ __ ] uh
there's the Victoria's Secret I do it
yes
those guys are pathological a friend of
mine who's used kids went to Dalton said
that one of the Headmaster's turned out
to be a pedophile that hi it was one of
the guys at hired apps that hired
Epstein ok math teacher there's a
pathology this is just Canada's so I
think people are wondering how how deep
does that underground world get fleshed
out and you know does it ever fully get
fleshed out but yeah you you don't think
it'll just be like this thing where a
bunch of people were charged like in
five years really bad go yeah names were
circulated but there was no
corroborating evidence and the judge is
probably problem it's like it'll it'll
be a thing in the news but like it went
away yeah you know someone be
embarrassed for a couple days or week
but you know you're later they never
actually like what the trial because of
some human emotion so many names that
come out that it has an opposite effect
where people get desensitized what I
mean yeah it's just gonna seem like I
mean the way people talk about like the
whole Russia probe but which is like
yeah the way I don't know how you can
objectively say it's a witch hunt I mean
right that's not a witch other stuff
people generally believe that I'm saying
is like and because there's a certain
value to looking at like when jane mayer
writes this article about our frank and
it's you know to exonerate our frank and
it's like okay yeah but so the world
that you guys set up is the world where
we do not question women right and we
don't tweet pictures of accusers in
scantily clad outfits which is what
they're not doing with this girl with
LeAnn tweeting or whoever accused
Franken Bette Midler's doing that and
other people are doing that so right
when you look at which is you know when
you look at the why
they're doing that to diminish your
credibility right yeah but so it's like
when you look at the molar report you go
well the world that you guys have been
campaigning for all the time is a world
where we don't take the word of
intelligence agencies at face value
right and that we look for deeper
motives in what intelligence agency we
require proof not that we're necessarily
conspiratorial but we require evidence
no sure and proof and I'm not saying she
a peach this all right like based on the
evidence that's been yeah I'm saying but
you look at the way he's acting not be a
criminai my point is in the same way
with this it's like you know you know
look at and go was it be to think I mean
it's like or these things it's like you
look at you go Oh ever think of Franken
right was woman stuff it's like yeah
like they've you're doing this [ __ ] but
it's like I lost right here Frank you
missing and Al Franken was not a
pedophile and I'd be surprised but me
honestly just just because a woman you
are a sketch where you were lusting a
woman and then she took partner doesn't
mean you were right to like grab her
tits while she's sleeping like I'm I
said I don't think he was trying to rape
her but you know it's like just that's
not cool there's gotta be alignment I
don't know what he did but but final
thoughts here today I don't it off do
you are you shocked if Epstein gets
killed no no I mean look these people
Gary Martin it was accurate not very
much Gary Webb people always end up dead
Phillip Marshall yeah it shows Mena
Chrissy's house I'm it's nowhere near
anywhere in California where I live
count I was shocked for a while with
this stuff because it's like the
question is like what is gonna kill him
and the who's the guy Hastings Michael
Hayes yeah and then into a tree right by
my one of my favorite restaurants in LA
I went right into a trick when you're
younger or your lesson initiated into
this kind of stuff you go well they're
not gonna be that blatant about it
people really question it people don't
question it no they don't so ya know
he'll have been in jail a look at Dahmer
I mean I
did you did you ask about the motives of
the guy Dahmer right you slain Maxwell
will start to they'll say she's mentally
unhinged yeah she had a psychic break
right she's Oh probably give her the
pump some little problem credible she'll
start saying the Queen of England better
do this which is probably true yeah yeah
but but it'll I mean that's the thing
yeah no but he'll he'll end up dead
III's there a cleanup team and Langley
now that's like well you gotta start
drugging these people we gotta start
slipping them things we got you know I
mean it's probably more like just guys
who's like it's kind of thing when
you're at Langley right this is you work
for Langley you're a guy like that Liz
or we're Frank who's like I Frank wizard
whatever his name was Frank sure senator
the guy who killed himself
I don't know point is he's got his
career guys these guys who were like you
know in the in the top 5% of the CIA
like they have careers built there and
so I can we let this guy do this [ __ ] as
gonna come out and so you handle it
right not because the agency cuz you're
gonna be in front of Congress explain
why or judge explaining this so you
[ __ ] take care of it like that Shekar
throughout the [ __ ] yeah burn the
tapes I mean I'm yeah whatever I'm
saying this these things are not always
the agency on the line of course it's
like your careers on the line so you
[ __ ] I mean the thing of Hastings uh
wasn't it like the general just probably
justified it on his own
or one of his [ __ ] subordinates
projects [ __ ] I don't know man he was
looking into an article on John Brennan
I don't know I'm saying like it's very
likely to me that Brennan príncipe but
yeah a parable to you yeah no I think
it's very easy to to the Hastings no
there's no doubt in my mind he was
murdered of course is murdered my point
is right it doesn't have to like the
murder doesn't always have to be ordered
from an official vantage point like of
course shit's coming out there's gonna
[ __ ] with a career yeah let's just get
you know ya know easily it could have
just been a scandal embarrassing the
Obama administration right but hey she
was working I mean who knows yeah yeah
man I mean it goes back to that James
Angleton quote where he said you know
when I sat in the room with the people
that it started you know
CIO is I was never certain of anything
that all these men would end up in hell
and then he took a drink and he said I'm
gonna join them there shortly
so it's you know it's that crew how well
do you think have you been surprised
with how much like the bushes in that
old world has been diminished how much
have they did like that they were they
were for a long time like how more in
the shadows and I feel like I don't know
it's a Carlyle Group not in with with
the [ __ ] in Korea they're in there
yeah I mean I think look poppies dead w
doesn't is W think really part of the
whole that whole world I know what he's
doing
yeah that's the thing is that sometimes
these things diminish because who's
taking up the slack that's true I mean
you know any family yeah I mean Cheney
kept the scandal going you know he's the
son that the probably never had or they
had their moment they had their era yeah
it seems like their eras over the
Clintons are done there they're playing
a half-full it's just a [ __ ] I mean
what we'll see about the old days we'll
have in the chamber that one kid I got
George P Bush they got a Pierce push I
don't know about him I mean who knows
but the look I mean like the Rockefeller
is like Rockefellers director at
Rockefeller really at a real one the
real not really there's a it's so funny
my friend goes to this went to this
party in the Hamptons with a girl named
Apple Rockefeller that's hilarious
I think that I think that the Clint like
Barbara said because we've had enough
bushes which we tried to run cuz the
country's had enough bushes yeah cuz she
knows she knows like they know she knows
that woman knows and shout out to russ
Baker and Reid family of secrets and you
know we're all still waiting on his next
Tom that woman knows almost everything
her husband knows yeah pretty close
she's you know she's [ __ ] writing you
know right blogger is like contradict
yeah yeah support support she knows yeah
and she knows what they did to get there
and she probably knows that the kids
barely have it yeah and that they
dragged w across the finish line it's
like that shirts a session yeah a
hundred percent he knows
like you [ __ ] thank you but who fills
that vacuum of the book look I mean I
don't know that you need to have people
it's the same feeling president [ __ ]
know that I'm not saying that right I
guess it's just the same wealthy
interests and wealthy families that
aren't as public
that are still kind of pulling the
strings
it likely we've always said they outlive
the bushes and that whole group of
people the Clintons were always servants
right bushes and the Clintons are kind
of servants of these other wealthier
families right and who's doing it now
the problem is or the well a guy like
yeah I got like Bezos I mean he's
wealthier than running wrong child right
Hank [ __ ] Rockefeller hack people are
coming in now
yes but that's where you're gonna see
and those Facebook knows more about you
than the CIA and this is like this show
right this is the next era those guys
have more power or as much power they're
the only guys that approximate the power
and the guys like JP Morgan and john d
rockefeller and Andrew Carnegie had
right as bad as it is that your stuffs
being sold I mean people who are like
it's become so [ __ ] uh in chic to
like she's on capitalism but it's like
you know yeah no one wants my dick pic
being sold for you know for and so I can
be advertised to but you know when the
power lies with the government you know
they do the [ __ ] you know blog is
this is not not the government was 100
percent the caucus is a nexus in the
Nexus yeah but I think when it's a when
it's the CIA doing it they're like break
they're toppling countries and more
visceral well know for a fact yeah
there's tons of CIA people with all of
those companies of course and you know
for a fact that it Chris had you said it
he was right the government and the
state and private corporations have
become this unstoppable immovable he
goes there's never been a more powerful
force well then this hybrid between the
and there's maybe nowhere that you can
glean I mean you can glean that
relationship in the most currently
in the most visible sense I think with
the tech companies because you see you
see through obviously security you see
this kind of merging and you see people
getting the platform then you see these
all these debates happening about speech
and then you know about privacy and all
these things and you can see that the
state and and these companies have kind
of merged in a sense sure I mean I don't
think it's I think is more friction
there I think it's a there is like I'm
sure there's certainly shift there
these companies are these masts I mean
they have all and they have everybody's
information right and that's what they
do their data mining operations sure and
and you have there's no way in hell that
you don't have you know I would almost
argue that Bezos himself is you know is
in a room with some very well I think it
depends easy they go look you your
wealth you what you're doing you know
we'd like to maybe you know have
meetings with you once in a while and
like you know pick your brain also like
let's you know you don't think they got
a number two or number three guy in
Amazon it's a [ __ ] agency plant
I'm sure they doing yeah I know about
yeah my point is more sorta like he
knows and they're like hey we want we
want what you know maybe don't open your
factory here because that [ __ ] is this
so I like I'm saying there's a lot of
these guys are geniuses is it possible
if some of those guys were were kind of
provided with the capital and and you're
put in those positions because they were
picked because they were geniuses
because they would play along I mean
it's possible but you look at the ones
that like I mean was what was my space
you mean like uh nutrition I'm saying
yeah were they all I think some remain
it was like you know I think it's like
anything else I don't think every single
one I was on some books originally I
mean like yeah yeah they became this
just adding a little more accidental
then I'm not saying it's not accidental
but during the period of an organic
development process do you think people
are monitoring that and then people are
saying okay we're gonna have to 2a
degrees I mean if you look at you know
what people say about DARPA you know
that the government is very much ahead
well technologically I think it's I
think it doesn't have to be that
anything it's just like they'll be it'll
be more like there's guys in venture
capital for sure or yeah work for the
agency right and work with hey yeah this
is some interesting technology here they
want some fun some money in fact yeah
I'm not saying it's that neat yeah well
what I am what I am what I am really
kind of afraid and what I think is
coming I think you're good is that
technocracy where they can take your
account what can be deleted they can get
rid of you they don't have to give you a
reason why if you don't play look all of
these apps Instagram now you can really
see it happening are you really being
shut up and I've talked to people that
said that's not true that that doesn't
you think that I'm not coming up in
searches I'm coming up like ninth down
and I'm verified and people are typing
in that's him Dylan yeah Tim JT I know
you but really yeah but I talked to
somebody said that they don't believe
shot of banning is an actual thing but I
they said that Instagram is playing her
out the algorithms to make the site more
friendly to advertisers because they
want commerce on the site and that's
what they want it to be they want it to
be as something where people go on and
sell and promote their businesses right
and in order to do that I think they
want to sanitize some of the content on
the site and I think that's what you're
gonna see across the board with a lot of
these sites yeah is that they're going
to try there's gonna be less discord
less at you know they're gonna try to
clamp down on certain words or phrases
or things like that and you can you can
already see it with with Facebook where
if you wrote like something positive
about Alex Jones they were like taking
it down all right you know so you could
see here the thing I go back and forth
with this but like the idea that like we
gave with a
the idea you're willing to let this be
your public space like yes it is a tool
that we use but a corporation set this
up and they did it for a reason right
they deserve to make money and if they
can't make money because people are
[ __ ] you know talking about you know
Hillary Clinton's you know bleeding from
her ovaries whatever these guys are
doing yeah yeah it [ __ ] with the money
so my point is but your people
everything they won't this is why I have
no faith it's one of the things like
people have no will to modulate their
use like they want they want to live in
this virtual world and it's done nothing
but Alamo here's what I'll say oh you're
doing Khamenei it's like they're making
it very hard right right is that you if
you do not have a smart phone good luck
with anything
what other option do people have I'm not
saying like if it's I completely but I
don't live my life on Twitter I
understand I'm saying you know anything
but what I'm saying is that it has
become so increasingly difficult to do
anything without a smartphone that you
have to have one true and you know one
of the reasons that everything is you
know happened in the way that it's
having I really truly believe is this
corrals people in a way that you know
nothing else ever has before right and
this is just such a [ __ ] tool of
people that want to dominate and it's
very easy for people that want to
dominate other people to basically have
have these services where you're putting
all your information out willingly
mm-hmm and and all these all this
information can eventually potentially
get used against you or right now it's
being used to sell stuff to you so
that's kind of like somewhat benign
right you know to an extent but later on
down the line god only knows how well
look if these are the public spaces yeah
I mean I don't know what we're talking
about as far as being used against you
but if you are talking all this [ __ ]
like at a certain point like it's either
real or it isn't like and if it is your
public space then like if people decide
that if you're anti-immigration that
makes you an extremist if people decide
I mean people decide these things if
they make you an extremist and you get
labeled an extremist you get kicked off
these sites you don't potentially that's
used against you when you're planning
employment or where I'm and by the way
if you speak out against Israel or if
you speak out against US occupation no
iris hedges if people on the Left have
been called Russian BOTS because they've
criticized the DNC and Hillary Clinton
and they're now called Russian BOTS
because so are we are we're really
showing the season were on destruction
where any critic of the state can be
marginalized but is this I mean yeah mmm
what I'm saying it's happening
immediately no no I'm saying you're
starting a work where do you think
that's really come from the state or
from whatever this weird cancel culture
we won't call it I do you think that's
engineered by like do you think this my
idea of like PC and like cancel culture
and like people and selective outrage is
something that's been kind of cultivated
by absolutely for the purpose of like
when dishing after troughs you like
bastard Trump won the election there was
a massive panic and there was this idea
that it had been and and by the way not
all wrong but that these sites who were
vulnerable to hacking and to being and
to being perverted by foreign States act
foreign actors you know people that
wanted to distribute information that
wasn't true so again I'm not saying that
it's neat and clean and that the idea
that the state is necessarily looking to
oppress people but they had to draw a
line around a lot of the whether it's
independent media or or or or people
that are going out and saying certain
things right and what happens when you
start to do that is you're you're you're
you're running the risk of identifying
independent media real journalists as as
as as bad actors or as conspiracy
theorists marginalizing stuff they're
saying
and this is a so does the state have an
interesting yet no is the PC [ __ ] are
these private corporations that just
want nice places for people to magic yes
no I but I play with you there know what
I was getting at movies like you think
they've like this has been cultivated as
a means of conditioning to like think
like look at Stalinist Russia yeah you
were just like a guy disappears and you
don't mention him again right and like
is that is this kind of precursor that I
think it's a precursor to the idea that
like did I think there the idea that
there is discourse on the internet that
is not acceptable to people in power
whether they're a private club I don't
see a huge difference between private
corporations and the state in this thing
in this Scott in this sense right I I
think that unacceptable discourse is
going to be marginalized or extinguished
if at all possible I've never believed
that the state had an interest in
promoting the free exchange of ideas and
that I don't really I don't I don't
think they for a long time I just count
because it was harder to search I guess
I mean let's just they were less old
Alex Jones have been around for a long
[ __ ] time right they decided to go
Adam not right after not even a few
years ago well look to be fair yeah yeah
been around for a long time and like
people were mad about it and then he was
going for the Parkland kids since like
RIT was again like so like it's not and
I understand that but I'm also saying I
don't think it makes anyone feel good
that you have a guy in an industrial
park in Austin reaching hundreds of
millions of people I don't think anybody
likes that I don't think the government
likes it and I certainly don't think
media companies like it and by the way
I'm not saying anything about Alex Jones
although after Epstein's arrested
certainly you know I'm you know it might
end with him winning the Medal of
Freedom and then we all realizing he was
right about Sandy Hook I mean I don't
know what I possibly did my thing is
this it's like the big I never get as
mad about the Russian collusion thing as
all right will do even though I do think
I'm sure was a real funny
mostly anti from sorry about it but that
being said it's like we you know we've
been doing
for [ __ ] decades sense yeah and the
other thing is Oh most of what they did
was planting fake stories right on
Facebook and yeah and and and you know
generating you causing real events real
protests were right we have look at that
setting up different you seen them would
you ever read that [ __ ] now no rumors to
my poll but my point is is we're
basically getting we're getting to the
point where I'm saying maybe we're just
too dumb to be governed yeah my uncle
said that once yeah he was quoting
someone I'm right my church or something
but the point is is like you know if you
can't if that's where we're at where
this can be this is all Russia needs to
do election but what are we preserving
what were we have we lost this country
what if Jeffrey Epstein before his
sentence gives the most beautiful
impassioned speech anyone's ever heard
one of these things Amazing Grace like
do we know what if he does this amazing
like speech that's literally amazing he
just like breaks down society and
everything that's hat you know at work
yeah it's just amazing and everything
but everybody's just staring at him it's
just admit the judges got tears in his
eyes has anyone ever made a speech that
was anything like that where you break
you a break in our society and you
weren't you doesn't mean heck no because
you you you you you yeah no I don't
think so the last guy was eisenhower was
okay watch evidence military-industrial
yes I mean you know I think it's in what
will end like this because we've done
another hour probably but you know I
think it really comes down to my friend
basically said we were talking about
I've seen you know a friend of mine goes
you got you gotta talk about something
and I go well I understand that but I'm
like we have two presidents were
actually implicated and stuff because
yeah but he goes and he looked at me
dead serious and this is the guy this
guy like right and he goes but who does
this really affect well these girls have
had their day in court
not really but these affect but that's
what they think that is not the minority
opinion right did the majority live in
your life the majority opinion is why
does it matter if the presidency human
traffic
if you literal evel's that [ __ ] I think
we've both grown cynical but I think we
both landed on if you can't fight
against you know pedophilia what are you
right
oh yeah right this guy it's not high bar
but there was just something funny about
him going not joking right not kidding
around he goes but who is this effect
like he goes doesn't affect like my dad
he said how would it affect like and
then you have to but then you up but
again like you laugh and it's funny it
is very fun no I'm laughing but it's not
I wish it was a minority thing because
if you you have to explain to people in
this country why it's a problem that
we're being run by lizard pedophile like
you have to say they don't as long as
there's no traffic and they can go to
Texas Roadhouse yeah I get the hot rolls
with the cinnamon butter day they go I
don't know you know people care about
traffic in this cuts what they really
care about anymore is trash it's got
worse than horrible how long do you
think before they go for another 300
bite of the Apple that's how great would
it be if it just keeps getting sloppier
yeah god this is whirling Allen with
like [ __ ] food tray it's a scene from
Naked Gun 3 you know I mean OJ's on
Twitter he's the most diligent person on
this is this some [ __ ] like guy a
leagues prisoner when you're dressed up
like you were little girl
there's an old prisoner dressed up with
like white and black stripes he is
wearing a Halloween prison costume he
doesn't even look like a prisoner she's
trying to kill him you know like I mean
this is yeah I mean look I'd be shocked
if anyone that we've really heard of
there'll be people who go down yeah but
like people who we know I just I I
because they is their stuff in the
reporting like his woman who did is
reporting do like a brand
yeah is there a lot of exposure
to operating sad it's a lot yet they
have a lot of messages and people like a
hotel rooms and I've seen sending girls
to hotels I mean listen so even these
even even the flip
I guess they got a lot of stuff but slip
helps yeah for mojitos you know I mean a
flip probably but a flip probably hurt
like it
what's his offense what's the defense
what is it like is the active defense
gonna be I mean I didn't I mean like
they were all they were pretending to be
kids I think I I don't great question
and he's got good lawyers where I'm sure
well it wasn't her she what's like his
lawyer and then der schweiz dominant you
telling me he's [ __ ] his located yeah
that's the defense by the way sound
there she was being like listen she's
good is there gonna be the country
doesn't want to trial for this right I
mean I don't know I mean headless and
dusky trial I guess that was perfect but
they had the Cosby trial things they do
you want I mean I don't know I mean
here's the thing outside of and this is
where my friend was probably right
mmm-hmm outside of certain pockets to
people does this even register to people
I think they keep their it look it's
getting around like it's getting yeah
but I think people probably like thing
of Epstein same when I think of queueing
on just like I think also people think
about Epstein is like ah there's
probably some girls that were under it
like wow I mean I don't think that the
dark recesses of the menthe like I don't
think people are hip to the the you know
living look it's hard to live tension
now how [ __ ] up the world is a lot of
people don't want to do it we've we've
basically said it's done nothing for us
no I mean I wouldn't go back I wouldn't
go back to not but we've never had a
choice to not no no and that's why we
became friends and that's why that
that's why we did the show was enjoyable
but we also realized with the show like
we do a lot less conspiracies now only
because we
I said this with mullin and we'll kind
of end like this people that are just
hip to this [ __ ] tend to think it's
gonna have like a series finale right
and they get what they want but what it
really is it's really a soap opera where
you age out of watching or you just get
bored of watching yeah you're like oh
they're getting married again
alright you know you just get sick of it
you get you just start banging your head
against a wall and you go yeah it's not
gonna have that resolution that's
satisfying for you well look it's been
going on for thousands of Europe I mean
there's more sophisticated now and we we
think that we're gonna see the great
comeuppance in our lifetime the Weir's
the thing and we're wrapping it up but
like yeah but what's probably weird
about us is that we think it's just like
a novel thing that the people in power
are doing but like that's why you get
power but if you if you explained
civilization to someone yeah like it was
a savage room you know whatever they try
believes of years ago yeah yeah we get
together we do all this and like in yeah
they did assume yeah the person will the
resources a guy in charge is a guy is a
run stuff it's like this idea that the
rich or like not like beholden to the
poor why would they be right and like
and the fact that like you know did they
exploit people and use them for them of
course they did right so like it's just
the idea like that's the weird thing is
that we have this cognitive dissonance
of like we think it should be better and
it should be better but it's never
there's no reason it would be right
there's nowhere to go
yeah there's nowhere really to go and
I'll tell you this folks if you think
for one minute that there's not another
island being built bigger and better be
built by the Pope be built by the
Vatican with water slides and if these
kids just slide right down the slide
into a furnace silly doing they're done
they were running [ __ ] for a long time
and for a while Epstein was like
business and they were saying hey
everyone come home right yeah they just
found bones from some person talked
about that well yeah what's going on
here here's what we've learned if we've
learned anything let the church run the
kid [ __ ]
do you think the Pope is right now on
the phone with like world leaders going
let us do what we've always done come
home try to privatize come back to God
come back to the church well this was an
epic podcast folks this is it it's time
to leave New York I'll see you soon
any parting words it's been a crazy
journey two and a half years on and off
uh look if you can explain to me why you
have hope some hopeful God yeah already
minded I believe it's possible for
people to do better this yeah this is my
overall thesis it's entirely the human
spirit can be indomitable right it's
entirely possible that we could get
together and if I can solve all these
problems and fix these things of course
we could but there is no evidence at all
that there's any will amongst the people
to even approach starting that the
people just don't care and we've been
plated and there is just no popular so
you know I mean go do some charity feed
the homeless so we can you know go out
and try and make the world a little
better on your end but like you gonna
ask me like yeah I don't see over people
bookie look at the people arguing on on
fun Facebook look at your parents yeah
look a [ __ ] teacher really yeah
really thing we're gonna pull through on
this one I'll end this with it with a
quote and an anecdote that I think sums
everything up it's from a bar that I
used to hang out it leases lounge and uh
I was there once with my friend our
Christmas Eve and we was there at the
bar there was a couple next to us that
we're doing cocaine and drinking and
this bar was a bar in Long Island where
there was a picture of a girl the the
owner the owner's daughter had died and
like a drunken an accident like a drunk
driving I said and he named the bar
after her and me and my friend Joe were
sitting there were hammered on Christmas
Eve and then there was this guy George
wood inherited all this money and then
this prostitute kind of prostitute woman
helped him spend like a hundred grand
and he's back living in his car
and they were doing coke on the pool
table
me Joe sitting there hammered and the
guy came out Steve who owned the bar
that now he had a little Santa hat on
and he looked at us he looked at us very
seriously and he goes I did this bar he
goes I created this place so that people
so the people without families would
have a place to go on the holidays
that's why I did this and then he just
took a line of just did a line of blow
and then patted us on the back and he
goes Merry Christmas and that's that's
the country we're living in yep good
night folks